Ukraine's military has posted videos of its soldiers launching strikes using us delivered
weapons called Himars.
These long range rocket launchers that can fire up to 53 miles are being used by
Keith to blast Russian ammunition stores and hamper crucial supply lines like this
bridge to the occupied city of her son.
Military analysts say recent attacks with the systems could be slowing down Moscow's advances in
eastern Ukraine.
The himars could very well enable the Ukrainians to push back
against the Russians in a very significant way.
But to turn the tide of the war and reclaim control of some Russian occupied territories,
keith says it needs more long range and sophisticated weapons as the U.
S.
Prepares to send another $1 billion in military aid.
Here's how high mars are helping Ukraine and which other american weapons could enhance keith's
capabilities.
Since the start of the war in late february,
the biden administration has provided a range of weapons to Ukraine.
Those include harpoon,
anti ship missiles and artillery units such as the M triple seven howitzers.
The military analysts say the delivery of high mars in late june has been a game changer.
That's because of the advanced capabilities of the weapons.
High marks have roughly doubled the range of the previously provided howitzers and defense
experts say they have greater precision and higher mobility than Russia's equivalent.
The B M.
36 merch which has a longer range,
they're also very easy to move and operate.
So the operators now are sitting in these high mars,
they're they're sort of they're comfortable.
They're safe,
they feel protect And the technology is quite sophisticated so they're
really feel empowered operators need around five minutes to set up the weapons to strike
targets but only need around 20 seconds to be able to relocate after they have fired.
And that's really important because the risk with artillery is the
possibility of counter attack by the Russians that they identify where this fire is coming
from and they respond they are all reasons why timers are strengthening
keys forces at a critical moment in the war.
For weeks,
Moscow has been bombarding eastern Ukraine with artillery heavy strikes,
culminating in Moscow claiming control over the Luhansk region in early july,
but the US rockets are now enabling Ukraine's forces to strike Russian bases.
These satellite images show an ammunition storage unit on july 11th and a day
later after keith said it was leveled by High mars so they've been going off to
Russian supply depots.
Exactly.
And sort of limiting the pace at which the Russians can resupply their
frontline.
That Siddharth Cashel,
a military analyst at the Royal United Services Institute,
he says Hi mars are forcing Russia to make adjustments on the battlefield.
So the Russians have adapted by doing things like moving supply depots
outside the effective range of timers.
What that means is now supply lines even longer,
which means that the time and logistical effort of moving supplies to the front
line is it's great as well as moving some of its equipment further away
from combat,
Russia has made targeting Ukraine's long range weaponry a priority.
This video released by the Russian Defense Ministry claims to show strikes on the U.
S.
Weapons in Ukraine.
That's a sign that Moscow sees the additional firepower as strategic.
The Pentagon said Russian claims that the systems were destroyed were false.
But despite initial success in slowing down Russia's offensive,
Ukraine says it needs more support to reclaim lost territory in the next stages of the
war.
The Biden administration,
which has sent $9.8 billion dollars in military aid to Ukraine amid the war,
has considered sending more advanced systems.
Western allies have been very kind of excited
and satisfied by the way in which the Ukraine have used these tools quite
effectively providing more of the systems.
They may provide more ammunition and longer range munition.
And then there's also been talk recently about providing the Ukrainians with
fighter jets.
That edition could bolster Ukraine's air fleet,
which is eclipsed by Russia's in terms of numbers of aircraft and more modern
fighter jets would allow Ukraine to strike behind Russian lines and to provide air cover to its
troops.
But so far the US has resisted giving Ukrainian forces weapons that could be seen as
escalating the conflict.
That's because of concerns from some U.
S.
Officials that the equipment could be used to strike targets within Russia and even if more
advanced tools are provided to keep Ukrainian operators will still need to be trained to use
them.
In the meantime,
Ukraine isn't expected to regain territory using high MARS alone.
Instead,
military analysts say they will continue to play an important supporting role.
So as the work runs on,
Ukraine is going to be in need of more,
pretty much everything,
whether it's tanks or arms ammunitions.
Um but it seems like the high marks will continue to be a really important
part of that mix.
Um And they've enabled the Ukrainians to make a statement of how effective they can be.
Mhm.